well there were a number of measures
announced today that we've been calling
for I mean particularly the so called
kickstart scheme that seems to be
modeled on what the Welsh Labour
government has done in the future jobs
fund that was introduced by a Labour
government previously so certainly we
did want some of those elements of
support to be introduced but I think we
are concerned that we're still seeing
from the Chancellor there's one size
fits all approach being taken to the
different economic packages particularly
the job retention scheme we do think he
needs to shift from that because
actually the big problem now is such
large numbers of people falling into
unemployment we need to help them once
they become unemployed but we need to
stop them becoming unemployed in the
first place as well just before we move
on to what he didn't do just back on
what he did there's a finance bill I
believe next week will labor therefore
be voting in favor of all of these
measures well I don't believe currently
I mean obviously we need to look at the
detail within that bill but I don't
believe we would be wanting to oppose
major elements of it at this stage I
mean in the case of stamp duty obviously
it's been quite a chaotic process but
the problem is with stamp duty cuts once
you suggest they're going to happen you
need to go ahead with them because
otherwise your meaning or you've seen to
people don't buy your house now and
that's really problematic when we've got
such big problems in construction so I
don't think we're going to be opposing
those elements but we do still need to
see change so that means that for
instance you will be supporting the
1,000 pound bonus for employers that
employ people who were on furlough
through November December and January
and even though the enormous cost of
that 9 billion a lot of that money will
go to employers who already will have
decided to bring people back and we'll
go just many many of the richest
companies in this country
why on earth you supporting a policy
like that if it does something like I've
just described well we have precisely
called on the Chancellor indeed I just
did that within the House of Commons
we've called on him to set out
conditions to make sure that it's not
used in that way that it would just be a
kind of deadweight cost we've sent
him to show us that it won't just be
money going to those employers who would
be taking people back on anyway you're
still you're still supporting but you
are still supporting this plan
well we consistently called for the job
retention scheme to be made more
flexible we're very very worried about
the fact that and less changes are made
it will simply have been postponing
unemployment episodes that for some
areas it will be hopefully incentivizing
employers to keep people on we would
want to support it but do I want to see
a more targeted approach absolutely I do
and I've been consistently calling on
the Chancellor to do that he's not
delivered it today but we're not going
to post something that goes part of the
way there so you will happy to back the
thousand pounds for companies even
though a lot of that money may well go
to rich companies and so employees have
already decided to basically bring their
staff back but we do want to see a more
targeted approach you know I'm
consistently on the record for having
said that the Chancellor's ruled out a
more targeted approach therefore if this
is what he's putting forward to try and
keep people out of unemployment then
we're not going to criticize that
unnecessarily the big big problem that
we've got now in the UK is unemployment
potentially rising up to its previous
record from the 1980s of three million
people Chancellor needs to be acting to
prevent that additional rise that
measure would help but as you said if
it's not appropriately targeted there
will be a lot of dead weight cost going
to employees I don't need that money but
you accept through your backing of these
schemes that the Chancellor's done
things today that are quite likely to
mean that some of the unemployment that
had been forecast won't happen well I'm
obviously really hope that will be the
case I do think that a more targeted
approach to the job retention scheme
than what the Chancellor has put forward
today and the self-employed scheme would
have made much more of a difference I do
think it would have kept more people out
of unemployment and it's not clear to me
that the the particular problems facing
the UK economy are being acknowledged as
part of this crisis we've seemed to have
the slowest growth in vacancies out of
many industrialized nations currently in
the UK we've got that specific
problem that means we've really got to
keep people out of unemployment and not
just be helping them once they become
unemployed